cette nuit permet aux gens d'évacuer
toute la haine et la violence qu'ils ont
accumulés en haut ça ne te rendra pas
ton fils tu te sentiras pas me
merci c'est une nuit qui caractérise
notre pays
réussir concitoyens ce sera une
tradition que nous célébrerons chaque
année participé à la première pu rien
dire au revoir
tu vas assuré frangé de table tout ça ce
soir zahia et toi vous allez rester avec
moi pendant la pure chance en sortira
tout seul nous sommes avec le docteur
abdel qui a eu l'idée de cette
expérience
docteur de la purge est elle politique
elle est avant tout psychologique
si on veut sauver notre pays on doit
évacuer notre reine pendant une nuit
cette nuit on va voir le bien et le mal
en chacun de nous le commencement de la
première énergie notre quartier
d'assiéger par les troupes d'un
gouvernement qu'on n'a rien à [ __ ] de
nous décrire à la sirène tout crime y
compris série d'homicides ça va les gars
du rhône et 12,1
y a des potes senti adore qu'on va
devoir protéger les gens il faut se
préparer au pire gouvernement remet
participation des fêtes vous aviez prévu
une participation plus importante
la nature humaine n'obéit pas aux lois
de la politique
[ __ ] c'est quoi
c'est désormais un militaire ça pue tout
ça
s'envoyer sur l'hymne des soldats
déguisés en civil pour purger le pays a
besoin que ce soit une réussite
personne ne va venir nous aider après
cette nuit plus rien ne sera jamais
pareil
et un truc c'est qu'on est là qu'est ce
que j'ai fait
du goût j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
souvenez-vous des bienfaits de la purge